Black holes. We're riveted by their
destructive power.
Black holes are dangerous.
Black holes are hazards.
Black holes are not friendly for their
environments.
There's just no good end to anything that
falls into a black hole.
Perhaps one of the most frightening objects
in the universe.
But what exactly are these scary objects?
Black holes are created when you get enough
matter in a small region of space.
This happens when a massive star dies and
collapses in on itself.
A supernova.
A black hole is the ultimate consequence of
gravity.
It's an object that has so much mass crushed
into such a small space that its escape
velocity becomes greater than the speed of
light.
They are a one way street.
You go in.
Nothing escapes.
Not even light.
But do black holes really deserve their bad
rap?
In some ways I think we set up black holes to
be more villains than they actually are.
Black holes suffer a bit of a PR problem.
I think there are a lot more menacing in
science fiction and popular media than they
really are.
There are trillions of galaxies in the known
universe.
And most of them have a supermassive black
hole at their center.
These monsters are millions of times the
mass of our sun.
Their immense gravity can send stars flying.
They're instrumental in choreographing the
dance of stars in their vicinity.
Supermassive black holes shoot out torrents
of lethal radiation and violent cosmic winds.
And gobble up anything that comes close.
Now scientists are beginning to realize
these cosmic giants may also have a creative
side.
Most people think of black holes as being
like giant vacuum cleaners in space, and
basically everything falls into them.
But that's that's not actually the case.
They're better thought of as the engines of
cosmic change.
Although black holes are the end states of
stars, they can actually influence the
formation of stars as well in a bunch of
different ways.
A galaxy's job is to make stars, but
uncontrolled star growth isn't healthy.
Too many stars can drain a galaxy's gas
supply.
Black holes are very important.
It appears that Galaxy evolution is tied to
black hole evolution.
We don't know exactly how yet, but the
marriage appears certain.
One idea is that supermassive black holes.
Act as cosmic control mechanisms.
Black holes can act like a thermostat in your
house.
If your house gets too hot, the thermostat
will kick on the air conditioner.
And if it gets too cold, it'll kick on the
heater.
Black holes do the same things for galaxies.
Supermassive black holes regulate star
formation by pulling gas in and shooting it
back out into the galaxy.
When these black holes are consuming matter,
they're drawing matter into themselves, but
they're also spewing stuff out.
Basically black holes eat like little babies,
very sloppily.
So a lot of what they eat comes flying back
out again.
They stars, they eat planets, but most often
they eat giant clouds of gas.
The black hole drags gas and dust into an
accretion disk around it.
This disk spins faster and faster.
Magnetic energy builds up.
With the accretion disk swirling around the
black hole.
There are also magnetic fields that are
going on.
The material is moving so rapidly that the
magnetic field sort of winds up, coils up and
forms a vortex like a tornado.
Astronomers call them jets.
These jets propagate outward, like freight
trains plowing through the galaxy over
hundreds and thousands of light years.
These are like death rays.
The Jets disrupt the star forming gas clouds,
limiting excess star formation in the main
body of the galaxy.
But in the very outer reaches of the galaxy,
they can spark star birth.
Things are more gentle out there.
You're not as close to the energetic heart.
So stars, planets and life can form out
there, partially because of the material that
the black hole has moved out there.
So black holes can have outsized influence on
the regions that they inhabit right around
them. They can prevent the formation of
stars, whereas on very, very large scales,
they can actually instigate the formation of
stars.
2018. Black holes hit the front page.
Scientists discovered black holes gobbling
up gas so fast that they seem to be
outgrowing their host galaxies.
It naturally makes the question come up How
big can a black hole get?
Now we have the answer.
They can reach size Triple XL becoming
ultramassive black holes.
Ultramassive black holes are so cool because
it's just mind boggling that black holes so
large can exist.
Ultramassive Black holes are very rare and
typically have masses of more than 10 billion
times the mass of the sun.
10 billion solar masses.
That's a ten followed by nine zeros.
Ultramassive Black holes are real beasts.
The black hole at the center of our galaxy
is 4 million solar masses.
Imagine black holes that are 2500 times
bigger.
That's what we're talking about here.
An ultra massive black hole this big would be
as wide as the solar system.
And weigh as much as all the stars in the
Milky Way.
There are inside galaxies that aren't a whole
lot bigger.
That really surprised the hell out of
everybody.
And in 2018, scientists discover a 20 billion
solar mass ultramassive black hole growing
faster than any other black hole.
This ravenous behemoth devours the mass of
our sun every two days.
These big black holes are really good at
gobbling up other things.
They literally eat anything.
They're monsters of the universe.
This kind of voracious eating can have
devastating consequences.
It blasts so much energy and turbulence into
the galaxy that stars no longer form.
And the bigger the black hole, the faster
the galaxy dies.
The primary thing these ultramassive black
holes do to galaxies is they shut down all
star formation. And so in that sense, they
kind of kill galaxies.
And so these things could even wipe out their
host galaxies.
Ultramassive black holes are a problem for
scientists to.
They might be the fastest eaters.
But that doesn't explain how they got so
large.
With these ultramassive black holes, these
black holes that are tens of billions of
times more massive than our sun.
You can't just grow them from the slow
accretion of gas over time.
There's just not enough gas and there's just
not enough time.
It gives us a new mystery to solve.
How do you make black holes that are just
that big?
There's not a clear answer so far as to how
these ultramassive black holes were formed.
People wonder if there some other mechanism
by which you could make black holes.
A mechanism so violent it also throws
supermassive black holes clean out of
galaxies.